[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal de
la rédaction de tv 78 voici les titres
de ce mardi 16 juin après plusieurs
semaines de mobilisation contre
l'épidémie au coeur des services les
soignants sont à nouveau dans la rue
les équipes de plusieurs établissements
hospitaliers heavy noah ont manifesté
aujourd'hui l'établissement public
yvelines hauts-de-seine un nouveau
président deux mois après la disparition
de patrick devedjian décédé de lakovic
les élus du conseil d'administration ont
nommé georges siffredi retour sur cette
élection
et ils ont réalisé des journaux des
vidéos des reportages photo organisé par
le centre de liaison de l'enseignement
et des médias d'information
le concours médiatique est proposée par
les académies trois établissements
yvelinois sont récompensés c'est un
mouvement qui touche toute la france ces
organisations syndicales paramédical et
médical ainsi que des collectifs ont
manifesté aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
plusieurs actions ont été menées les
soignants se sont rassemblés à partir de
13 heures devant plusieurs hôpitaux
exemple à versailles et à
mantes-la-jolie avec manon varaldo et
mickaël millero forte mobilisation du
personnel soignant ce mardi 16 juin dans
les yvelines au centre hospitalier de
versailles andré millions une centaine
de professionnels tous services
confondus à des filets suite à l'appel
des syndicats qu'ils se sont réunis
devant la structure à 13h en faisant
beaucoup de bruit
on va à tâtons récurrentes rappelé
l'importance de l'hôpital public et puis
les enjeux il ya autant de talent public
et je pense qu'on a tous étaient
conscients de cela au travers de la
crise due qu'au guide et on souhaite que
ce qui a été initié avant la crise se
poursuivent après la crise de sorte à ce
que les places publiques soient
préservés même constat à l'hôpital de
mantes-la-jolie pendant la période du
coc vide 19 le personnel soignant estime
qu'il a prouvé son engagement
parmi leurs revendications des moyens
supplémentaires pour travailler on a
plus de pied à perfusion on a plus de 2
pousse seringue
on a plus de chaises roulantes et on
fait quoi pour travailler pour certains
collègues qui l'ont fait avec des bouts
de ficelle avec des sacs plastique en
guise de bouse qui mixe qui a vraiment
mis en évidence la carence du système
hospitalier à l'heure actuelle depuis
2015 on a perdu 109 lits
d'hospitalisation et près de 250 postes
est ce qu'il ya eu une modification de
son action gouvernementale absolument
pas les soignants demande également une
revalorisation de salaire
l'intersyndicale réclame 300 euros pour
tous
[Musique]
cette soignant le travail à l'hôpital de
mantes-la-jolie depuis 15 ans elle se
mobilise avec le collectif inter
hôpitaux c'est investir dans la santé
des français
l'hôpital public il est indispensable
pour le bon fonctionnement de cet état
le privé ne fait pas le même travail que
l'hôpital public le privé sélectionne
ses patients nous on sélectionne pas en
30 secondes
les soignants attendent des réponses du
gouvernement d'autres mobilisations
devrait être organisée dans les
prochaines semaines dans les yvelines
l'épidémie continue de reculer en france
et dans les yvelines 466 malades étaient
toujours hospitalisés hier lundi soit
quatre au moins des chiffres du week-end
le nombre de réanimation n'a pour
l'heure pas changé avec vingt-six
patients concernés autre chiffre
inchangé celui des décès 509 personnes
sont mortes dans les hôpitaux yvelinois
depuis le début du confinement et les
retours à domicile continuent quant à
eux à progresser portant le chiffre de
personnes guéries 2032 pour le
département ce mardi 16 juin se
déroulait le conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine les élus étaient
rassemblés à la scène musicale à
boulogne billancourt pour respecter les
règles sanitaires en vigueur
à l'ordre du jour l élection du
président et du vice-président de le
pays
c'est georges siffredi président du
conseil départemental des hauts-de-seine
qui est élu à la présidence un reportage
de mathilde et demi avant de commencer
la séance du conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines hauts de
seine un dernier hommage est rendu à
patrick devedjan pierre bédier vice
président et président par intérim de le
pays a par la suite proposé la
candidature de son homologue georges
siffredi président du conseil
départemental des hauts-de-seine à la
présidence de le pays et que
j'ai su qu'il était candidat à la
succession de patrick devedjian de
prendre aussi sa succession
l'établissement public
interdépartemental puisque c'était un
accord qui avait été passé avec patrick
devedjan les hauts-de-seine aller
jusqu'en mars 2021 et après on discutera
de tout ça sur ce qu'on espérait c'était
ne pas avoir discuté que la fusion soit
faite sur 79 votants georges siffredi
est élu à la présidence de le pays à
l'unanimité pierre à bédié et lui aussi
élu pour la vice-présidence avec les
membres du bureau se succéder à patrick
devedjian qui était personnalité donc
pas évident ça vous met des réponses
étaient supplémentaire sur les épaules
mais je vois tout cela sereinement parce
que beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
faites et qu'avec le présent bédié nous
entendons très bien nous connaissons
depuis longtemps convaincu par l'apport
de la fusion yvelines hauts de seine le
président de le pays veut travailler en
étroite relation avec les yvelines
notamment sur le projet de la plate
forme d'établissements et services pour
personnes en situation de handicap
psychique ou atteintes d'autisme
pour l'instant sa liste peu en france
les parents sont obligés d'envoyer leurs
enfants d'aller vers l'étranger c'est ce
qu'on va faire au niveau des autistes et
ça c'est vraiment une première et je
crois que c'est primordial les travaux
commencent et on est un exemple espérant
en france et qu'on va donner l'idée à
beaucoup d'autres de s'engager dans
cette voie
l'ouverture de la plate forme est prévue
pour la fin de l'année le prochain
conseil d'administration de
l'établissement public
interdépartemental yvelines
hauts-de-seine se déroulera le 15
décembre
[Musique]
le second tour des élections municipales
c'est dans douze jours d'ici le scrutin
nous vous présentons les divers
candidats engagés
direction la verrière avec nicolas d'un
billy les têtes de liste une nouvelle
dynamique pour la verrière et est
arrivée en deuxième position avec 36%
des suffrages le 15 mars dernier
nous lui avons donné deux minutes pour
vous convaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les points forts de notre livre c'est du
sang neuf
c'est vrai qu'on a une majorité
municipale qui aux responsabilités
depuis 40 ans et là on apporte une
nouvelle énergie avec des personnalités
une nouvelle ont des sensibilités
diverses et qu'ils aient envie de faire
des belles choses pour la ville je peux
vous citer ludovic raul qui a des
grandes compétences dans tout ce qui est
marchés publics et dans tout ce qui est
gestion de l'immobilier
on a une vive rousseau agnel roussel on
a fouillé moussa d'arriva tu mets qui
représente la jeunesse on a radouane
ouardani émail diallo qui symbolise
aussi tout tout tout le quartier du bois
de l'étang on adoucit brahim qui est sur
orly par le point fort important notre
programme je dirais que c'est
l'éducation
on a envie de mettre en place les outils
les plus innovants les outils
pédagogiques qui permettent de réussir
le soutien scolaire gratuit
l'étude dirigée des cours d'anglais par
visioconférence pour former la bonne
oreille avoir le bon accent mais
également l'initiation au jeu d'échecs
pour former à la pensée logique
mathématique à la la stratégie est
également les coûts de programmation
informatique sur des petits robots
[Applaudissements]
ce serait la mobilisation d'une équipe
de médiateurs sur le terrain en urgence
pour veiller au calme dans nos quartiers
beaucoup d'habitants se plaignent des
incivilités
ils se plaignent des rodéos à deux roues
ils se plaignent de la saleté voix des
habitants ont dit j'ai jamais vu la
verrière en six salles et donc tout cela
il faut une équipe de médiateurs sur le
terrain pour sensibiliser pour rappeler
les règles qui permettent de bien vivre
ensemble ça suppose des droits mais des
devoirs qu'on respecte bien si on veut
continuer à vivre ensemble dans notre
belle ville à l'épreuve et les électeurs
auront le choix entre trois listes parmi
elles agir tous pour villepreux issu de
la fusion entre les listes du premier
tour agir pour villepreux et tous pour
villepreux cette nouvelle liste est
menée par valérie bas on les écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est d'abord l'origine de sa liste nous
sommes créés contre les projets
d'urbanisation massive qui devait
conduire à une augmentation plus de 50%
de la population
c'est ce qui en moins de dix ans voilà
c'est ce qui nous réunit et nous voulons
aussi un autre style de gouvernance de
la ville parce que ces dernières années
ont été exécrables du point de vue des
villes provient nous apportons en fait
une nouvelle vision de la gestion
financière avec d'autres solutions à
préconiser c'est vraiment de ne pas
comment dire pippo thème et sur la
gestion de la ville
on peut vraiment faire autrement là il
avant que vides
il ne restait plus que cinq cent mille
euros dans les caisses de l'état et on
n'arrête pas de rabâcher que la ville
était bien gérée bien depuis le début
nous disons qu'il ya une autre façon à
faire et que nous nous voulons
reconstituer le budget de fonctionnement
en arrêtant de fonctionner sur celui ci
pour financer l'investissement qui nous
coûtent plus cher après en
fonctionnement c'est quand même un
cercle infernal qu'on veut absolument
briser urgence en fait ce sera
d'organiser la rentrée scolaire
puisqu'il a des retards dans l'école il
ya on parle de classes surchargées avec
cette gestion financière et bien
finalement il n'y aura plus une atsem
par classe comme c'était le cas dans des
maternelles donc ça va poser de gros
problèmes pour les fans et la rentrée et
puis bien sûr cet été puisque tout le
monde ne pourra pas partir en vacances
les projets des uns et des autres sont
perturbées donc quand le cirad
d'optimiser l'animation de la commune
après avoir voté un budget qui dix jours
après l'élection sur lequel on aura
finalement assez peu d'action à faire
[Applaudissements]
elle la situation sanitaire poussent les
candidats aux municipales à repenser
leur manière de faire campagne
les militants de la liste avez-vous
voisin avance mené par béatrice spira
ont trouvé une solution sillonnaient la
ville à vélo avec leurs affiches et en
faisant tinter les sonnettes c'est ce
qu'ils font tous les samedis depuis
trois semaines l'idée est aussi de
rappeler aux habitants que le second
tour arrive bientôt trois mois après le
premier pour rappel la liste avec vos
voisins avance de béatrice pira est
arrivé 3ème au premier tour derrière
unis pour voisin emmenée par olivier
afonso et alexandra rosetti 2020 la
liste de la maire sortante
[Musique]
on s'intéresse maintenant à trois
lauréats yvelinois d'un concours ce
concours s'appelle médiatique s'il est
organisé par le clemi le centre de
liaison de l'enseignement et des médias
d'information ce concours est ouvert à
tous les médias scolaires et lycéens
qu'il s'agisse de journaux de blogs de
raoued radio ou encore de réalisation
vidéo de reportage photo les
établissements sont évalués par un jury
composé de journalistes professionnels
l'interview est menée par manon varaldo
les résultats ont été dévoilés trois
lauréats du concours médiatique se situe
dans les yvelines
l'école paul bert à conflans sainte
honorine a remporté la deuxième place
dans la catégorie journaux en troisième
place le collège jean moulin de croissy
sur seine pour la catégorie radio et
enfin le collège albert thierry denis
mais a décroché la troisième place dans
la catégorie vidéo
séverine pont c'est olivier vous avez
piloté ce concours médiatique
combien d'établissements participé cette
année alors cette année malgré la
configuration très particulière on a
quand même 49 établissements qui ont
participé donc c'est quasiment semblable
aux années précédentes avec
une forte proportion de journaux sous
format pdf ou blogs et puis on va dire
une vingtaine de médias radio ou télé
dans les quatre départements de
l'académie et parmi ces établissement le
collège albert thierry animer la classe
des quatrièmes à est une classe avec un
projet médias les élèves ont réalisé 3
min journaux télévisés sandrine duchêne
vous êtes professeur de technologie mais
également professeur principal de cette
classe comment avez vous mis en place ce
projet avec vos élèves
alors c'est au départ grâce au génie et
puis ensuite on a travaillé avec nora ma
vie qui travaille pour le journal
d'arctic est venu à la rencontre de nos
élèves et ils ont eu l'idée de
construire ce journal ils sont vus une
fois deux fois trois fois par trois fois
une foire virtuelle et deux fois en
présentiel où ils ont pu travailler de
choisir les sujets et ensuite par la
réalisation finale que bp devra elle
nicolas bout d'aile vous formez avec vos
collègues
un trio médias vous avez créé tous les
trois un atelier web tv il ya 11 ans et
cette année ce nouveau projet comment
les élèves se sont répartis les rôles et
les sujets étaient justement ce qui
avait le plus compliqué parce que les
élèves le parent toujours sur des sujets
extrêmement vaste extrêmement compliqué
et le plus dur a été justement de
ramener sur des choses qui était
faisable notamment sur cette période
assez réduite et donc il a fallu
travailler dialoguer avec eux pour
amener sur les suivis un peu plus précis
mais c'est d'eux que les sujets sont nus
et pour la répartition des rôles entre
les élèves eux qu'ont choisi c'est ce
sont mignons
souvent on affiche selon leurs affinités
mais ceux qui ont choisi justement leur
répartition c'est d'ailleurs bien pour
ça qu'on avait plutôt des groupes de
filles plutôt des groupes de garçons
puisque voilà ils se sont réunis selon
les liens d'amitié et le tournage a été
réalisé dans les conditions d'un direct
avec le matériel de la web tv à tes news
du collège albert thierry michael joue
cros les élèves étaient motivés ah oui
ça leur sont vraiment impliqués
complètement dans le montage et la
réalisation des journaux les conditions
du direct en vous le disiez puisqu'on a
la chance d'avoir au collège à un studio
télé et avec de quoi faire plusieurs
caméras en même temps des éclairages
donc on avait à la fois les journalistes
sur le plateau et les techniciens en
région vous pensez que c'est une plus
value pour leur enseignement
ah oui ce alors qu'il travaillait
notamment l'oral on sait qu'avec
aujourd'hui le grand oral du bac en
interne est préparé donc c'est ce genre
d'activités d'ateliers permet de
travailler ça et puis le travail
d'équipé l'organisation la réflexion des
sur les sujets sont abordés et en
l'occurrence à des sujets assez assez
pointu corps et l'ont même si le
confinement à perturber cette édition le
concours médiatique ça a été maintenu et
le calendrier adapté elle les prix du
concours médiatiques sont été décerné
par un jury composé de journalistes
professionnels pour récompenser les
meilleurs médias quels sont les lots
attribués séverine conserver pour les
élèves
alors ça c'est un partenariat
effectivement avec des médias qui sont
sur le territoire de l'académie de
versailles donc des quatre départements
donc on a toute une diversité de l'eau
qui vont être des récompenses de livres
par exemple on à la fondation varenne
qui récompense en chèques livres
on a des visites quelques visites dans
des médias qui accepte de recevoir les
élèves on a des interventions de
journalistes en classe on a tv 78 qui va
vous offrir des places de cinéma
c'est très divers en fait on a vraiment
chaque partenaire s'adapte un petit peu
à la classe qui doit récompenser donc on
remercie nos partenaires et surtout les
membres du jury des professionnels qui
apportent je pense vraiment des conseils
très éclairant pour les classes la
prochaine date important du concours
médiatique le 23 septembre
la remise des prix du concours national
ces résultats était une première étape à
l'échelle de leur académie demain
mercredi 17 juin le jury national
annoncera lui aussi son classement
le retour à la normale se multiplient
dans de nombreux sites saint quentinois
le 4 mai dernier les sept déchetteries
saint-quentinoise accueilli à nouveau du
public avec une nouvelle organisation
respect des gestes barrières et prise de
rendez vous à partir du 22 juin l'accès
sera à nouveau libre sans prise de
rendez-vous et aux horaires d'été toutes
les informations sont disponibles sur le
site ce qui point fr et c'était l'une
des annonces du premier ministre edouard
philippe le 28 mai dernier les salles de
cinéma peuvent ouvrir le 22 juin ce sera
le cas du ciné 7 à elancourt il n'avait
ouverture avec bien sûr des règles à
respecter masque recommandé pour les
spectateurs lors des projections
obligatoire dans les espaces d'accueil
files d'attentes distancié et pour sa
réouverture deux films sont notamment
programmés en avant le dernier pixar et
la bonne épouse avec juliette binoche et
yolande moreau le patrimoine aussi
trouve petit à petit ses portes au
public après le château de versailles
c'est celui de rambouillet qui accueille
de nouveau ses visiteurs l'ancienne
résidence royale a bien sûr dû revoir
son organisation regarder elle les
équipes le craignais un peu mais le
public a répondu présent
ils sont 250 avoir découvert le château
de rambouillet dès son premier jour de
réouverture de mémoire mon grand-père a
séjourné lors de son service militaire à
rambouillet donc ans
on s'est dit que c'était l'occasion de
se promener là pas très bien en plus
très intéressante ya beaucoup de
mobilier beaucoup de reconstitution de
scènes notamment le dîner du g6 donc
très intéressant vraiment à faire l'idée
c'était de
de sortir de paris et d'être plutôt à la
campagne donc et un foret faire une
balade en forêt et quand on s'est posé
la question du temps et de comment
l'espace et notre journée assez
naturellement la visite de deux des
lieux gérer un peu historique s'est
posée et 45 personnes peuvent être
accueillies en même temps contre 150
visiteurs avant le confinement nouveau
lieu d'accueil réservation des billets
d'entrée en ligne et circuit à respecter
comme tous lieux recevant du public le
château de rambouillet a revu son
organisation sans ne rien cacher de son
histoire le parcours naturellement un
amène à aller de l'avant et non pas à
faire des retours en arrière donc par
exemple toutes les pièces en cul-de-sac
donc il
obligeait les visiteurs à se croiser ont
été fermées par des mises à distance
elles sont visibles de l'extérieur mais
on ne peut plus rentrer à l'intérieur on
arsenio gras fièr meubler un petit peu
le château pour donner voilà un peu plus
de contenu pour un aux visiteurs de
nombreuses animations ont été annulés
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
la chaumière aux coquillages et la
laiterie reste pour le moment fermé mais
les équipes planchent sur de nouveaux
rendez-vous dans les jardins du domaine
autre centre des monuments historiques à
reprendre vie le château de maisons dans
les yvelines les visiteurs peuvent à
nouveau se réveillant châtelain c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
vous pouvez retrouver cette édition sur
notre site internet ou sur notre
application mobile belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]